[MUSIC]
We know that people who
fit in enjoy their work.
They enjoy the experience of
being in an organization.
They're emotionally rewarded by it.
And we all aspire, I imagine,
to create organizations where
members of the organization wake up
in the morning and want to come and
where they feel attached and
indebted to the organization,
and mostly indebted to their peers.
And by creating a healthy cultural
environment, we can facilitate that.
[MUSIC]
It's the experience of coming to
an entirely different cultural context,
that makes visible to you
how pervasive culture is.
But also how invisible it is.
So, like an example I always like to
use is when I came to the States for
the first time and people would say to me,
let's have coffee sometime, and
I would take that as a literal
invitation to having coffee sometime.
And I didn't quite understand that in
was fact like a very nice pleasant
way to finish a conversation, but where
the intention is actually, I don't want to
have coffee with you, but let's just
pretend that we had a nice interaction.
And then so I would initially
respond by saying, yeah, sure,
let's have coffee sometime, when?
It took me a while to figure out that
that wasn't the intention of the speaker.
And it's only when you're kind of
transposed to very different cultural
settings that suddenly your lack of
cultural skill becomes apparent to you.
And that moment to me kind of
highlighted how important but
invisible it is, and
why it's important for us to study it.
[MUSIC]
Culture is about the systematic
distribution of beliefs and
cognitive understandings
across a population.
And it's very difficult to
measure people's cognition.
Historically we've been doing this by
asking them questions, through surveys.
Problem is that surveys
are not very good instruments,
because we lie to ourselves,
we lie to others.
We sometimes are not very well
attached to our cognition and
especially our un-self-conscious cognition
acts, what makes it un-self-conscious.
Add to that the fact that it's not
very feasible to ask people questions
every day, time and again.
It leads to huge attrition and
disengagement.
[MUSIC]
The Internet revolution has
made a variety of behaviors
that up until recently were
not recorded recordable.
And they leave a trace,
from how we communicate online to
our purchasing behaviors,
everything now leaves a trace.
And marry that with the computational
capabilities that we now have.
Our ability just our ability to compute,
on our smartphones we now
have computational capabilities that
are akin to what NASA had in 1985.
And that, with new machine learning tools,
artificial intelligence, deep learning,
the ability to analyze
unstructured complex data and
to reduce it to measurable outcomes,
both of these
together bring us to the golden
age of cultural analysis.
[MUSIC]
So we were very lucky to have
collaborated with a few organizations
already that were willing to share
information deriving from the email
exchange amongst their employees
over a period of multiple years.
By now, myself, my colleagues and all the
members of our lab, we've analyzed many,
many years of data being exchanged by
members of multiple organizations And
there's a lot of information
culturally that we can derive
by looking at how people use
language in their emails.
[MUSIC]
The reason that language is such
a useful way for us to analyze culture
is because language is probably
the most important medium through
which cultural information is
exchanged between individuals.
I'm not interested in whether when you and
I are talking are we talking
about how are we going to address
this particular customer problem, or
are we going to talk about HR issues, or
are we going to talk about
the Christmas party that's coming up?
What functionally we're exchanging
is immaterial to the analysis.
What's interesting is whether in
discussing these topics, we're using
the same kind of linguistic styles as
a reflection of our cultural alignment.
So whether we're using aggressive and
brief language or
whether we're very apologetic.
And you can just think about all your
email exchanges, there's a significant
difference between saying dear so and so,
it was such a pleasure to meet you and
I hope that this is not
an intrusion on your time, etc.
But if you don't mind, at your earliest
convenience, can we please meet?
And you can say the exact same thing but
say, hey John, can we meet next week?
Without all of the introductions and
apologies.
Functionally you've exchanged
the exact same information, but
there's a lot of cultural content embedded
in how you chose to present yourself and
the problem and the question.
And that's precisely what
our analysis tries to infer.
[MUSIC]
Swear words are very, from a symbolic
point of view, they're very aggressive.
Somebody drops an F bomb, it's noticeable.
It's not a subtle thing that
people do as they speak.
And if you think about the organizations
that you've been in or
the various cultural contexts in which
you've gone through through your life,
there's a lot of variation in
terms of whether it's allowed or
really a faux pas to use
swear words in interaction.
And you can imagine that there
are certain organisations where not only
do people swear a lot,
they use swearing as a means to project to
others their authority and their tenacity.
And you can imagine, at the other extreme,
that there are organizations where
the use of swear words is
perceived as an offensive and
inappropriate way of handling yourself and
would be interpreted as aggression.
So it's the same use of language, but
it's interpreted very differently as
a function of what's
normatively appropriate or
inappropriate in these
two different settings.
[MUSIC]
In the research that I do and where we
analyze how people use language in their
interactions, their habitual way of
speaking inside the organization, whether
they swear at the appropriate level is a
very strong signal of the extent to which
they're aligned or misaligned with
the normative expectations of their peers.
The mere information about whether or not
an individual is correctly using language
insofar as how language is being used by
others and reflecting their expectations
and beliefs about the world is a very
strong indicator of whether that person
reads the cultural code and whether
conditional having read it correctly,
whether that person has the motivation
to behave in a culturally compliant way.
[MUSIC]
So you can imagine that some people
realize that it's inappropriate to swear,
but they swear nevertheless.
And that decision,
whether conscious or un-self-conscious,
has a lot of information.
They're either signaling to others that
they don't want to be a part of
this group, or they might feel so
secure in their position in
the group that they believe that
by behaving in a non-conformist way,
they can signal to others their
uniqueness without undermining
their position in the organization.
So there's a lot of information
in these very subtle and
automatic decisions that we make and how
we communicate information to one another.
[MUSIC]
Discoveries on culture are both
exciting and daunting.
They're exciting because
we're starting to figure out
the constituent components of this
opaque thing that we call culture.
They're daunting because we discover how
complex it is, how difficult it is to
manage, and how not one size fit all or
one shot exercise it is.
But again, they're exciting
because I think we're at this
moment where the research can
be translated into insights and
into methodologies and
into tools that can inform managerial
decisions in a way that would make
management more effective and
more rewarding to everybody involved.
[MUSIC]